はじめしゃちょー質問ウィン
ナーｧｧｧｧｧ
ｱｯ ｱｯｯ
ｱｯｱｯﾊｯﾊｯﾊｯｯﾊｯｯﾊｯｯｯ
と言う訳で大変お待たせしました
質問ウィンナーです
募集期限を超えてからも
めちゃくちゃコメントがあったんですけども
一応合計は皆様のおかげで
20万コメントを超えました
本当にありがとうございました！
ちょっとね20万コメントは
ちょっと流石に一人だと無理でした
八月いっぱいをもって僕の家を旅立つ
弟と一緒にコメントを見させていただきました
本当にたくさんのコメントをありがとうございました
もう夏も最後です
ゆる～く適当に質問コーナー行きまっしょう！
こんちょぉ！
「こんにちははじめしゃちょーです」の略です
おい　あぁ！？
おい　あぁぁ～↑！？
寝ましょう♪
帰れ！　お前が帰れェ！！
ありがとうございます
なんか……
ドキドキするね！
うぅ
はい。
（な、なんなんだこの人は、
アイコンとのギャップが、ひどすぎる！)
俺は、
君がどこにいようとも
何度でも
見つけてあげるよ。
プ！！
シャー芯じゃねえわ
元気だよ。
シャー芯じゃねぇわ
ありが、とう
そうめんじゃねーわ！
針金じゃねぇわ!
ニラじゃねぇわ
しらたきじゃねぇわ。もうなんで…
エリンギじゃねぇわ
頑張るよ
ヤ―コンじゃねぇわ
なんでも言っときゃいいみたいなこの風潮はなん
君を愛してる
チュッ
ず～るるるる
お゛お゛ぇぇぇぇぇ
う゛う゛ぉぉぉぉぉ
におい、におい、
う゛う゛ぅぅぅぇ
うぐじゅ
あぁん？
すいません、はじめ先輩
許す!!
やだ
出来てねーわ
待ってるよ　ホントに頑張ってね！
自分のやりたいことやったほうががいいと思います。
辞めたいと思ったらやめましょう
やりたいと思ったらやりましょう
多分まわりを気にしてちゃホントに何も出来なくなっちゃうので
もう何にも気にせず
自分の思ったことをやったらいいと思います。
応援してるよ！
サーモン！
何言ってんの？
はじめ！(はい)ペッペッペー！
1！
ペッペッペー 2！
ペッペッペー3！
ふーう
もうやめよう、おい、なんでやらした
おまえきっもwww
やめてあげなよ
(1つのコメントで世界が救われた瞬間であった。)
ｱｧ？
好きな数字は?
114514(イイよ 来いよ)
1919(いくいく)
810(野獣)
ファッ！？
114514(イイよ来いよ)
1919810(いくいく野獣)
ファッ！？
日本語で
どうした？
母の似顔絵か。
内容によっては僕も家に帰れなくなりますからね。
似顔絵ならきっと許してくれるはずです。
髪の毛はちなみにショートヘアなんすよ
マジ自分の親を書くって難しいな
難しいけど多分だいたいこんな感じだと思います。
母さんごめん
はい！
は?!
♪～
はい！
あ、大好きだｙ
誰だよ
さきちゃんか...
さきちゃんなら
例えば さっちｙ
さっちゃん
うんこ
(いろいろ言う)
はじめしゃちょーじゃないけど...さっきー
ち※こ
みんなやめろー！！
あのこれもよく言われるんですけども
Twitterの僕のリプ欄見てもらったらわかるんですけどもほぼ8～9割は女の子です
えへ
動画見てくれてるのは男の子のほうが多いんですけども
やっぱTwitterは女の子がすごい多いんで... 男のみんな
もっとリプを送ってくれぇぇぇ！！
ハッハ。
世界一ファンキーなくしゃみ
オウブルブルブル！
プルプルプルバシコー！Hello,YouTube!
うううう、、、、
出れないんだって！！
ああああああ！！
オゥ！？
(アヴリル・ラヴィーン)
（こんにちわ。こんにちわ。台湾人。）
（はじめだよ）
（俺は台湾が好きだぞ！）
(俺は台湾に行きたいぞ！）
（来い！）
（こんにちわ！はじめ！あなたは今幸せ？）
（うん、わたしは・・・
違う！)
そうだぁぁぁ！！
（あなたは「変態」ですか？）
NO!!
（はじめ！はじめは私を愛してる？）
(うん、愛してるよ！）
誰だよ！！
はじめ！私ははじめをめっちゃ愛してるよ！
ほぼ日本語じゃない?
ア　オアぁ
おい！
あっはっはっはあああぁぁぁ…。
おあああああっはああああぁ！！！！(泣)
あ゛あ゛あ゛あ゛あ゛あ゛あ゛あ゛あ゛あ゛あ゛あ゛あ゛
あ゛あ゛あ゛あ゛あ゛あ゛あ゛あ゛あ゛あ゛↑↑
ｱｱｱｱｱｱｱｱｱｱｱｱｱｱｱｱｱ↑↑↑
ｱｯｱｯｱｯｱｯｱｯ…
\DON/
あ゛あ゛あ゛あ゛あ゛あ゛あ゛あ゛あ゛あ゛!!!!!!!!
は(おい、
ト(何?
は(トモヤぁ
は(俺は怒ってんだぁぁ！！！
ト(知らねーよ
じゃ最後にぃ
皆でぇ
あごあごぉ？
はい！
ト(うるせぇ
ふｗ
ﾌﾞﾙﾙﾙﾙﾙﾙﾙﾙﾙﾙﾙﾙﾙﾙﾙ
ｱｯｱｯｱｯｱｯｱｯ
(これをするメリットを考えたとき、)
(はじめは、)
(何も思いつかなかった。)
プウウウウゥゥゥ！！！！！
あ、あぁ、んなぁ！
あぁ！
パァン
あ、あ、あ、あ、
危な！！！
うるせぇぇぇぇぇぇぇ！！！！！！！
はい皆さんいかがだっだでしょうか
質問コーナーでございました。
今回ねぇ僕結構かなりのコメントを採用したので、
中々急ぎ足になっちゃったんですけども
ほんとに皆さん面白いコメントいつもありがとうございます。
またね、こうよくタイミングで質問コーナーできたら、是非皆さん、コメントをお待ちしております。
皆の衆、夏休みが終わってもいろいろ頑張りましょう！
じゃあな！
ペ
ぺ